retour en france avec une étude de
l'institut pasteur qui permet d'en
savoir plus sur la flambée du virus du
chikungunya
pourquoi la maladie c'est elle à ce
point développer si rapidement sur l'île
de la réunion
voici la réponse le virus a muté il
s'est adapté à de nouvelles conditions
climatiques
nicolas chateauneuf mathias barreaux
depuis l'année dernière un réunionnais
sur trois la contracter le chikungunya
fait désormais partie du quotidien de
l'île avec son cortège de malade
affaibli par la fièvre et d'importantes
douleurs articulaires avant l'épidémie
le chikungunya était un virus assez mal
connu mais aujourd'hui les chercheurs de
l'institut pasteur ont certes un peu
plus sur son évolution en séquençant son
génome
ils ont ainsi confirmé que le virus
présent la réunion provient bien d'une
souche d'afrique de l'est qui s'est
répandu via les comores avant de
s'étendre à la réunion puis aux
seychelles à madagascar et à l'île
maurice
deuxième enseignement le virus a connu
une mutation en septembre 2005 jusqu
alors il était porté par aedes egypti un
moustique peu présent la réunion le
virus change alors sa couche externe
pour trouver un nouveau porter ce sera
aedes albopictus un autre moustique qui
lui est très présent la réunion
l'épidémie peut démarrer
le virus a muté et si vous les acquis
vous aussi une clé qui permet de rentrer
dans les cellules de moustiques et s'y
multiplier de manière beaucoup plus
efficace qu'avant et donc en se
multipliant clairement il devient au
contraire le virus a plus de chances de
se transmettre à l'homme
l'étude montre également que certaines
mutations du chikungunya pourrait être à
l'origine des formes plus sévères voire
mortels constatés à la réunion le
décryptage de son génome permettra
peut-être d'améliorer la lutte contre la
maladie
la santé encore avec 1